à marseille on s'organise pour lutter
contre l'épidémie
les marins pompiers sont mobilisés
depuis jeudi devant lier à chum elizaran
et infections pour faciliter l'accès au
dépistage du coronavirus depuis une
semaine l'établissement dirigé par le
professeur didier rahout permet à tous
les habitants qui le veulent à de se
faire tester à l'institut peu effectué
jusqu'à 2500 tests quotidiens sur des
personnes avec ou sans symptômes
sur place les pompiers ont établi un
poste médical écouter l'un d'entre eux
le rassemblement est inévitable et par
contre les distances de sécurité sont là
sont présentes et sont recommandés
régulièrement quand on monte de la files
d'attentes pour leur rappeler qu'il faut
garder une distance de m entre eux et
puis les personnes dont les équipes du
masque que l'on a chez nous a donné
notre rôle plutôt là et pédagogiques
c'est-à-dire d'informer les gens que
tout le monde va être testée puisque
c'est ce qu'on nous a dit vous allez
passer par notre notre table pour être
orientés et après aux alentours de 17h
18h on essaie d'évaluer par rapport à la
file d'attenté les gens qui sont
susceptibles de passer et après sinon on
conseille aux gens de revenir le
lendemain parce qu'ils ne pourront pas
passer dans la soirée